I want to review some of the theory that
we introduced on Friday but I actually
want to do it in a slightly more
rigorous way because all I was trying to
do was give you a feel for this idea but
now it's time to go go full-on dive deep
into the rotation and define this in am
a really concrete definitive way so I
want you to remember we were playing
around with this idea of limits with
geometric progressions which have a
ratio a common ratio not a common
difference a common ratio that you
multiply by over and over again and what
we notice was with a particular bunch of
series not all of them I'll come to then
not all of them in a second
but with a particular bunch of series
like say this one when you take that
Conn ratio and you multiply again and
again and again and again and again what
you find is that that common ratio apart
which has been raised to this power it
goes towards zero yeah for example here
the common ratio being 1/2 when you
multiply 1/2 by itself repeatedly you'll
get 1/2 1/4 1/8 1/16 32nd and it gets
tighter and tinier and tinier forever
right so when you think about it going
towards that limit it really does become
zero but we said this doesn't always
happen there are plenty of counter
examples I can think for example of the
opposite sort of like this in this case
no such convergence happens right as you
multiply by the common ratio it just
gets bigger and bigger forever and
nothing nothing gets approached if that
makes sense
ok so therefore I want to put a hard
algebraic condition on this right you
can say in two different ways you can
choose whichever way you like but I will
tip my hat as to which I prefer in a
second so the first way you can say is
that what you want is for the ratio to
be making the series smaller not bigger
that make sense or I should say making
the terms if you want needs to be
smaller not bigger what you're saying is
I want that common ratio to be less than
1 so for example 1/2 is less than 1 or
3/4 is less than 1 anything like that
will make smaller than what's more than
1 but you actually have to put another
side on this inequality because for
instance
if you have a look at a common GP like
this I want you to think about that
what's the common ratio in this case
it's it's negative 2 now negative 2 is
less than 1 isn't it but that's not
going to have a limiting some do you see
why think about what happens I actually
going to add on a few more terms here
etc the idea is we were looking at the
partial sums and we wanted them to
approach something yeah what's the first
partial so I'm going to be equal to it's
just 1 right that's the first partial
sum
what's the second partial song it's
these two so that'll be negative 1 and
as you go and progress the third partial
sum you add this to the next term which
is going to be 3 and then negative 5 and
then what about to 11 these partial sums
aren't going toward anything okay so
we're not going to get a limiting sum so
this on its own is not enough I actually
have to say you have to be above
something as well what do you have to be
above you're less than 1 I need to be
above negative 1 right you see so that's
negative 2 yeah and it makes it bigger
bigger and bigger but so long as you're
between negative 1 and 1 you will get
these terms getting smaller and smaller
and smaller that's what you're after
ok a more succinct way of saying that if
you have a look being between negative 1
and 1 is to use our absolute value
notation from earlier in the year if the
absolute value of R is less than 1 those
two lines are saying the same thing
those two inequalities are the same so I
kind of like this one because it's more
succinct and it gets it the fact that
what's important about this number are
what's important about the ratio is that
it's small it's size is small it
actually doesn't matter whether it's
positive or negative so 1 is it small
enough you will get this happening over
here ok so on the basis of that since
that R to the N goes to 0 we define the
limiting sum s as
this the limit as n approaches infinity
of your partial sums right that's what s
event is we have a formula for the
partial sum it's this fraction do you
remember what it is and do you remember
which one would make most sense to use
given the condition I'll give you a clue
it starts with an A okay now we can't
put R to the N minus 1 here like that's
a perfectly sound use of the partial sum
formula however the particular kinds of
common ratio that I've got they're all
going to be small ratios small issues so
on this too no matter if I had R minus 1
I'm gonna have a negative down the
bottom okay so I was try to avoid that
so in fact I'm going to use the other
form which is 1 minus R to the N which
gives you 1 minus R on the bottom okay
now see this bit here see where it
appears get rid of you oh I keep
forgetting that I've lost my other
colors yeah that's why this guy here
there it is right that's going to
approach 0 so I can evaluate this limit
like so you might remember us to read
this last time and stuff kids without
yeah so all I end up with is this this
remarkably simple formula that's the
limiting son okay so a common use of
this is where the recurring decimals
that was what we had a look at very
briefly at the end I just kind of gave
it to you really quickly so I want to
show you how this is what 6l is about
how to recognize what's happening in a
recurring decimal okay so for example or
I might just put a little something for
you recurring decimals
if you think about a recurring decimal
like this zero point say a 107 107 107
dot this is the limiting some it's been
defined for you it's a number but what
we want to show is wait where does that
actually come from in terms of all of
this well I can write this as a GP and
therefore I can use this limiting some
idea right I can separate it out into a
bunch of terms have a look have a look
there's the repeating part so the first
one's going to be 107 over what this
would be a thousand right thousand like
so so that's fine the next one over is
this guy here well it's three zeros in
addition so therefore it's not going to
be 107 over a thousand it'll be 107 over
in this case it'll be a million but you
can save yourself some mental effort
here and also some writing zeroes all it
is is a thousand times a thousand right
now which actually makes it a lot easier
for us to see that it's a GP what's the
next one going to be 107 over thousand
cubes so in writing it like this
I've already highlighted there's a
there's the common ratio or appearing
it's on the DeMeo okay so I can say this
equals and I'm just going to launch
straight into my limiting song I'm gonna
say a hundred and seven over a thousand
that's my a so that goes on the
numerator and then I've got one - don't
forget you're actually making these
smaller so your common ratio is little
write less than one so don't say it's a
thousand and you can see the thousands
growing but that's not the common ratio
it's one over a thousand okay I think
it's helpful not just helpful I think
it's mathematically sound at this point
to say since I can only use the living
some formula limiting some formula only
has meaning when these conditions are
met right like you can actually put this
this GP here you can put it into this
formula and you can get a No
it just doesn't make sense because the
limit business didn't actually happen
for this particular common ratio so I
think we should actually justify the
fact that we've used this formula I'm
gonna say since R equals one over a
thousand namely the absolute value of R
is less than one so this is what allows
you to use this super super simple
formula because otherwise it's invalid
all right now I can just simplify out so
if I go one hundred and seven on a
thousand what's the actual denominator
now after I simplify out a look 999 over
a thousand and you'll know you've done
this right because you've got that
cancelling that's going to happen on the
top of the bottom okay so here's our our
top now just as a bit of an Internet to
this this is very easy to apply when
it's like oh I can see the exact thing
happening but sometimes you get once
that slightly different so for example
just look up for a minutes just so you
don't miss me writing this I could ask
you to do this but I could just as
easily ask you to do this now this is
not the whole thing is not a recurring
decimal like what's that for going to do
well it's not that difficult to work out
because I still have a GP here right
still my GP so what will I do that's
different I can think of two things that
I'll do that's different
have a think is the R is the common
ratio still gonna be a thousand one over
thousand I should say this is still 1
over a thousand to go from turn-to-turn
hmm well it depends what you think the
terms are right let me ask you another
question is this guy here part of your
GP well it can't be can it because
whatever you multiply by to get to the
next term or it'd be the same thing to
get the next one next one next one so
what you've got is like a GP here plus
some loner hanging out on the side so
you're going to deal with that as a
separate fraction that's okay so let me
just write this back as its original
question and you can help me start off
and then finish how I would have it if
there was a
0.4 out the front 107 107 okay think
what's 0.4 as a fraction for over 10
that's that
so you've whoops it is e you've dealt
with him in a big deal and then your GP
begins now the first one won't be 107
over a thousand anymore because I've
made it 10 times smaller yeah so this is
gonna be ten times a thousand you'll see
in a second why I've separated these out
rather than write to just ten thousand
what's the next one going to be have a
look there is right there yep very good
so the ten is still there but I'm making
it a thousand times smaller just like I
did before except a little further okay
and I need one more to establish the
pattern great does that make sense so
now this is 4 over 10 plus and then here
comes the GP so you can go ahead and you
can do this for the same reason and off
you go okay you will then get I'm
guessing it'll be a 107 over not 999 but
everything is 10 times smaller yeah so I
guess it'll be nine nine nine zero 5990
there you go plus four over ten and you
can put those things together and you
just get a different fraction okay